no bit of a change in pace uh father ted
made him a household name but now the
actor and stand-up comedian ardalo
hanlon has written a new crime thriller
his latest novel is set in a fictional
town on the irish border during that
uneasy transition to peace a place which
seems pretty familiar to the one where
arnold actually grew up and i'm very
pleased to say ardell joins us on the
program very good morning
good morning to you and thank you for
having me on no it is it is a genuine
pleasure and you will not believe the
number of messages i've had from father
ted fans uh asking me to ask very
specific questions but let's talk about
the book first shall we it's called
bruja tell me a little bit about it well
it's um i suppose on the surface it's a
funny bleak um
existential crime thriller set in the
border region of ireland yeah um
it's uh set in a small town i think it
um it observes the the niceties of small
town life and the pieties and
hypocrisies
um and i've always been quite interested
in that disconnect between the how
civilized and beautiful these small
towns are the the great sense of
community and the neighboriness and uh
and yet you don't have to scratch the
surface of any small town in ireland or
britain to uh to to to find the the
violent undercurrents beneath the
surface
um and uh i i was just interested in
exploring that area you know i grew up
in a part of the world where
there is a culture of silence um you
know a slight uneasiness given its
proximity to the border and and the long
association that the border has with
sort of lawlessness and uh
smuggling and later paramilitary
activity so
my story is about a person who went
missing some years previously and the uh
attempts by a trio of investigators to
find out what happened this person and
why
well
as someone who comes from a small town
himself i know exactly what you're
talking about arnold but but i wonder
obviously to what extent then the work
that you do them this your second book
to what extent the work that you do is
it is autobiographical or at the very
least kind of inspired by the upbringing
that you yourself have yeah
i mean it's it i suppose it is in terms
like the observations would be mine a
lot of the detail would be would be
stuff that i'm very familiar with i mean
like any novel a novel is a sort of an
alternate reality
but i suppose it is rooted in a real
place
the geographical features are i think
you need those you borrow geographical
features you borrow architectural
flourishes
um you might borrow a verbal tick from a
real person or or the way a person walks
or the way a person
speaks but um
and you know and i suppose all the
characters are manifestations of the
writer at some degree or another but
it's not autobiographical in the sense
that like
you know the events are not based on
real events necessarily i mean
as a kid i was a very watchful kid very
wary uh i think i was quite observant i
was a news junkie from a very early age
like from about the age of seven i used
to race i i used to race home from
school i mean when sky news arrived on
the scene i was made up i i
i used to arrive home from school at the
age of seven to read the paper from
cover to cover like i was a very
old-fashioned slightly precocious kid
and and then of course i was glued to
the nightly news and this was during the
70s and 80s at the very height of the
troubles in northern ireland so i was
very informed by the carnage that was
happening just five or ten miles across
the border um so
you know i i i mean a writer's job i
think is to uh have a look at the dark
side and and report back with the news i
think that's a kind of an idea taken
from from joseph conrad
yeah um
i have to admit your first book talk the
the talk of the time best seller i
remember reading it and actually
strangely enough that the author who i
was most put in mind of was irvin welsh
actually but the other thing i remember
is that i read that book quite some time
ago or what 25 years ago i think it was
that it came out i mean i've heard of
difficult second albums and but you know
this is yeah this is something else
well you know i was waiting for the
right idea um you know i think a novel
is is a massive undertaking and
i
you know i i had started and stopped
other novels in the meantime i didn't
have much joy with that and uh i suppose
i was burnt by that actually it was a
very it was a very sobering experience
you know to start something and spend a
lot of time on it and realize it was
rubbish eventually
um so i kind of i kind of bited my time
until i had the right idea and more
importantly the the space and time to
give it
um i think you have to commit and uh you
have to you have to eliminate all of the
distractions
and you know to be fair i was i was
quite busy in the intervening years
finally i got around to it
i i think i think i think that is i
think that is very fair enough um
regardless we're going to have to let
you go in in a moment or two but i i
can't have you on without at least
referencing um father ted and of course
father to go maguire the character that
you played when you guys came together
as an ensemble did you recognize pretty
quickly just how much of an impact he
would have in that you know people like
me would you know still be singing you
know my lovely horse or decades later
i know i had absolutely no idea i mean
you know we had a good
like
instinct that it was it was funny but we
didn't really think anyone would watch
it and we certainly didn't think that 25
years on
uh people would still be watching it i i
think
i think you know it has endured
um i'm not quite sure why i mean it
still has a lovely innocence about it i
think one of the reasons possibly is
that it is set in a remote island which
you know if it were a real place it
wouldn't have changed very much in 25
years and likewise priest fashion
doesn't really change much
over the years so it has that timeless
quality
yes that's one way of putting it um i'll
i'm afraid we have to leave it there but
let me quote um father ted
and and say good luck with the book uh
adler hanlon thank you so much for being
with us really appreciate it cheers
thank you
take care